so we're on um we're on number two row
number two which is outline the
following Network administration tasks
okay so you could call this you could
call this Network administration however
however I think an even better name for
better subheading for this when you have
a look at what all of these are they're
really all about people or all of those
people okay and so in some ways you
might call this a more descriptive name
might because sorry administration is a
very broad term it's just like I'm doing
all the stuff to make sure this will
work okay
but you may also call this at least
these particular tasks you might call
them user management user because all
along we've been kind of implying this
right then a network is made up of
what's the basic building block of a
network so remember the node correct
right which is an anode is a is any kind
of device that you can hook up to a
network okay by the way that sort of
draws out an important distinction
because there's printers and then
there's network printers and the first
can't be nodes and the second ones can
okay so for instance one of the things
that might distinguish those those two
is that if you go to your home printer
how does your printer connect it to your
computer
probably by USB and if you rewind it
back say 10 or 15 years back into Maya
day you had something called a parallel
port which is the same kind of idea okay
but if you want to a I'm a nerd so hook
into a network for a printer it's not
gonna plug in by USB
how's it going to connect program you
got two options um these days you can
get it by Wi-Fi you've got a lot of
printers that are actually wirelessly
connected or more common codes a bit
cheaper they'll hook in the same way
these computers view which is by
Ethernet okay so a lot of printers like
consumer printer
they won't even have that port there so
that kind of printer is not a network
printer it couldn't be a node yeah
that's correct so you sort of have a
software solution which is okay you've
got your printer
okay and it's hooked into one computer
by USB okay and this connection is not
designed to be shared okay I remember I
was talking to someone and she said hey
how come I can't get one of those USB
splitters like a 4-way port and like
hook it into that and I've been cooking
all my computers to it well that'd be
kind of like hmm it's kind of like
squeezing four lanes into one eye on a
word it's not really gonna fit it's not
designed for that kind of traffic
so anyway you can get software solutions
that'll let other computers hook into
this one computer and print by USB but
it's extraordinarily like printers are a
bit of a black art like that that sort
of weird they don't really work even
under the right circumstances so this
way you're kind of asking for things to
go wrong and for printing to not work
and another kind of thing so a better
way is to actually have a network
connection and that would not connect to
a computer but to any Rama okay that's
more common anyway sorry the reason why
I was talking about this you attention
huh see what I did there
is that we've been talking about nerds
but really what that implies is you've
got people who are using those nodes
right I assume they're kind of important
okay so for them to reside on a network
an administrator needs to carry out all
of these tasks bless you okay so let's
start with a cup management account
management
all right now I can't management you
might think especially the give this
subheading and this first item that this
is a bit redundant right isn't account
management the whole thing and the
answer is no what's the difference
between a user and an account user
account
hmm how would you how would you
distinguish between them yeah just take
text a bit if this is tricky isn't it
it's not it's not a distinction we
usually think about do I have another
stab Poppaea okay so we're talking about
a difference between the level of access
or the privileges if you like I think
we're on the right track here let me try
and distinguish this we need you know
we're on let's go to a website shall we
somewhere like say okay here we go
sir right now oh why am i a user of this
website I am uh what logic do you say
I'm a user of this website
cuz I'm looking at I can I can click on
all kinds of things I can even start to
put things inside a basket and start a
transaction right but do I have an
account here no I don't which is why
it's saying you know if sign in/sign up
whatever okay so I'm a user but I have
no account does that make sense what
difference would it mean to me or to the
website whether I have an account or not
we already mentioned one namely
privileges I can't actually buy anything
here like complete a transaction without
an account what are the differences
either yeri ah bingo okay there's the
big distinction let's come back to you
okay so let's get another color this is
a really important point to get the
different account and a user is the
amount of infamy
that is known about these two things
okay
so right now most of you who are on a
not a laptop and a normal computer most
of you are using a particular account
that has nothing to do with you what we
call that and the cat that has nothing
to do with you I think actually most of
you know this word but you just don't
think about it faster than gee a guest
account yes account so it's guess
because they don't really know any
information about you but they're still
letting in user okay so in some senses
right now I'm using a guest account okay
it just doesn't say so okay so when the
user gains an account that's associated
with them the big difference is
information okay I guess the count
doesn't really have much information
associated with it right what kind of
information
would we associate with an account let's
start real basic real basic one of the
first things you type in when you want
an account username
what else what else yeah okay so I
suppose we could um gather those and
like sort of contact details quantity
does anything else how is this some
account
well house there has the network going
to distinguish you use and your username
from someone else stop someone else from
using yours a password thank you okay
password um sometimes another thing that
you might providers say your real name
okay not all the counts are gonna ask
for that but a lot do it for example on
Facebook and Google+
they sent a lot of waves through the
fortunately the social media journalism
when they stay enforced or I call a real
name policy right you can't sign up
without a real name I remember a little
while ago I was trying to set up a
Google+ account and I wanted to call it
mr. woo and they wouldn't let me
they're like mister it's not a real
first name go back heard of until you
come back with a real name okay which me
really sad your parents actually called
you miss stuff but anyway um then you'd
be like mister mr. woo um so here's a
set here's a star okay um so here here
is the difference in account and a user
you can be a user without an account
without an account okay user without
okay but you can also go the other way
okay
for instance if any of you have ever
tried to share a document with me okay
on Google Docs right so you go to that
window up the and the top right you
press share right and then a new dialog
box comes up and you start to type my
name so you start typing in tomber you
or and then it does am it starts to
order complete right so starts to guess
who are you trying to think of right and
then suddenly there's like 15 mr. words
what's up with that has anyone ever
noticed that okay um so what's going on
there's just the one user namely me okay
but I have many accounts why would I
have many accounts and maybe you have
many accounts for different things
because I want to do suspicious illegal
activities
why do I have many accounts so you can
never use without account or a user with
many accounts okay well I think the key
to answering this question why would
such a thing like this exist is really
going to be addressing we have a look at
the next thing